l'évolution humaine comme j'aurais voulu
qu'on m'explique on m'a appris à l'école
que l'homme descendait du singe
une idée que j'ai depuis bien imprimées
dans mes petit ménage pourtant il est
advenu tantôt et depuis je n'y comprends
plus rien qu'on me dise que c'était faux
et qu on avait juste un ancêtre en
commun est ce grave docteur
mais c'est à n'y rien comprendre
l'évolution serait fausse et on me
l'aurait fait à prendre
rassurez-vous mon ami ce n'est pas faux
et c'est mieux que de ne rien savoir
mais il faut juste réaliser que c'est
peu par rapport à ceux des caches
brouillard c'est l'heure de reprendre
l'histoire des découvertes dans l'ordre
chronologique pour voir si cette
hypothèse est juste du point de vue
théorique
tout commença avec l'homme de néandertal
en 1856 ce fut une grande première car
de toute l'histoire c'était le premier
mineur fossiles jamais découvert humains
en tout cas un gros cerveau outil très
fins feu pâturer rites funéraires
si semblables que nos ancêtres sont
aussi les leurs car plusieurs fois et le
sib rieder l'histoire de nos origines ne
pouvait commencer par aucun autre de nos
frères k n'y a finalement qu'un seul
point une particularité des singes sur
laquelle on diffère c'est la présence
massive et saillantes au dessus des yeux
qu'une grosse arcade sourcilière plus de
ressemblances avec les sages et on
aurait classé néandertal avec les
gorilles mais presque identique à nous
c'est bien à représentants et un de
notre famille l'homme de java homo
erectus pour les intimes fut découvert
ensuite un homme au visage plat mais à
la boîte crânienne plus réduite
9 centimètres cubes environ soit juste
entre nous et le cerveau d'achat pensée
et des outils parfois symétrique comme
des bifaces mais en plus grossier il
nous révéla que le genre humain eu un
temps un cerveau plus petit mais rien
d'autre de bien distinctif pour le reste
de son anatomie
nous entrons à peine dans le xxème
siècle et le meilleur reste encore à
venir car en 1925 au plus profond de
l'afrique
devinez ce que l'on va découvrir museau
proéminents et boîte crânienne de la
taille de celle d'un singe banal
démontrèrent quand sera le pit et cus et
l hominidé connu le plus banal ce ne fut
pas peu dire car jusque là tous les
fossiles étaient européens ou asiatiques
mais australopithecus lui placé pour la
première fois nos origines en afrique
ce n'est que bien des années plus tard
que cette théorie fut confirmée quand
les datations montre elle que ces
fossiles étaient plus vieux que deux
millions d'années
vous connaissez maintenant l'essentiel
mais en vérité il en existe bien plus
homme de flores ardipithecus toumaï
kenyan trope ou bien par entre plus
inutile de tous les connaître
rassurez vous car tous montés que
raffiné le très court et synthétique
portrait que plus on nous avons brossé
analyses génétiques et fossiles ont
depuis montré que la racine du genre
humain peut être suivis en afrique
jusqu'à il ya 7 millions d'années au
moins nous tous aux minimes et
partageons la marche debout sur nos
pattes de derrière qui se traduit par
une entrée par le dessus du crâne de la
moelle épinière
de plus les en panne de pièces en thrace
demain les ca lightly constituent des
témoignages directs de nos ancêtres et
de leur dis p 10 et si vous n'êtes pas
encore convaincu que tout my
australopithèques ils sont proches
présents sachez que l'absence de kent
hypertrophié est aussi une
caractéristique du genre humain
alors l'homme descend du singe oui mais
si vous décidez d'en rester là
sachez que c'est en apprenant qu'on se
rend compte de tout ce que l'on ne sait
pas
cette phrase très simple est incomplète
garder ça dans un coin de l'esprit ce
n'est pas parce qu'on vous dit que cela
il faut que les relations humaines mais
aussi dire le contraire ce serait comme
prétendre pouvoir démonter la tour
eiffel avec les dents parce qu'un jour
vous avez fait tomber un château de
cartes d'un seul bâillements ciné
aventure vous souhaité formuler les
choses de façon aussi simple mais moins
simpliste on y suggérant la nature
d'ancêtre commun plutôt que d'une ligne
droite déterministe souligné
l'arborescence et les ramifications dire
que singer hommes forme d'une même
famille et suggéré que le chimpanzé est
plus proche de l'homme qu'il ne l'ait du
si vous voulez vous rappeler que sans
l'homme il n'y a pas de définition aux
singes alors dites vous simplement que
l'homme et le chimpanzé du centre d'un
même singes